kassow ich wollte die nicht überrumpeln
aber hey es hätte nur vorteile
wir würden uns wiedersehen nicht ich
musste meine sachen nicht hin und her
schleppen und und ich wäre im proberaum
verstehe also daher weht der wind
na ja das würde viel zeit sparen die wir
für uns helfen lotte und reza zum
beispiel wo sie leider gerade überhaupt
kein gutes beispiel
hast du denn heute morgen was immer hoch
der frühe vogel fängt den wurm
kompressors verwandtschaft zu besuchen
für uns zwar erreicht doch essweins
übernehme jede küche
wir bieten beide unsere gerichte an und
dann gucken wir mal besser ankommen ein
feststellen ach bald fragt über und
seine klausur für die abendschule ich
besuche die vormittags kurse und lerne
während du die küche sauber macht
da kommt morgen er werde details mit uns
besprechen
schon jetzt aber eigentlich stimmt das
fotoshooting soll so bald wie möglich
stattfinden
in den nächsten zehn tagen das dekanat
markt überhaupt nichts gesagt machen so
schnee das wirtschaftsministerium dringt
zuerst müssen wir die pm
dann kommt der launch der kampagne mit
dem release des piloten möglichst viel
publicity ist unsere oberste priorität
haben so wenig zeit
unser konzept ist bisher nur eine gute
idee wir brauchen eine produktionsfirma
die das shooting in so kurzer zeit
planen und umsetzen kann weil wir wir
haben keine erfahrung damit
doch lukas sein lebenslauf
kommst du voran
früher als diener und nicht zu hause
gewohnt haben uns immer super verstanden
ich verstehe sie einfach nicht mehr ich
dachte sie vertraut mir
und dann habe ich mich an seine
bewerbungsunterlagen erinnert ich habe
sogar seine referenzen gecheckt er kann
ein solches projekt auf die beine
stellen
überraschung gelungen was hast du dir
noch ausgedacht
wir arbeiten als team lukas hat sein
letztes projekt gerade beendete ich hab
gestern die letzten rechnungen
unterschrieben und habt ihr endlich
einlenkt sozusagen
wir werden miteinander ausgehen bald
bald ist interpretationssache ich will
nichts überstürzen
viel wichtiger ist dass wir ein gutes
arbeitsverhältnis haben stimmt das finde
ich auch
wie auch immer lukas für die produktion
die konzeption übernehmen wir gemeinsam
die das wird unser durchbruch tour
damals die geschichte mit dem export
unser vater weil gegen die beziehung ich
habe immer zu ihr gehalten auch wenn es
am ende nichts gebracht hat und jetzt
das reza das kann sie doch nicht bringen
ich musste etwas sorgen ich bin gespannt